notorious gangster Robert handle REE hey
hey hey what's up we logged into GTA and
we did some fun stuff today tell me what
happened today was the release of GTA
online newest DLC called lowriders and
it's exactly that you get to customize
currently up to six cars two of them
being new cars and you could have
customized them interiors hydraulics
paint jobs rims just a ton of awesome
stuff but did come out as well our new
clothing options so you get like bomber
jackets that are really cool like
jerseys hundreds of new items and then
you got four new hairstyles yeah three
of them are cornrows and they look great
especially yours you have like gray hair
so it's like gray corn looks awesome and
you had a band that you customized yeah
olan like pick my ride style oh how many
speakers were there like a hundred
speakers I've never seen like in my like
in real life I've never seen a car with
so many speakers so if this vehicle
actually exists in real life I am blown
away yeah cuz you would be blown away I
would be London speak literally the bit
the bass will blow me like four blocks
away yeah it has lights under the floor
under the car and that yeah I draw thank
you bouncing up and down in the Straits
interior you had plush you had a bobble
head I mean you went all out and then we
did drove around and got cool footage we
got cool footage and then we came back
to that same it's called Benny's
original motor works is like the new
kind of location where you can mod more
heavily these six so currently has six
vehicles you can do all the hydraulics
and stuff the original car of the van
that's a new one's called a moonbeam I
was like oh damn is really cheap it's
only like 30 grand 32 grand and then you
get into shavon it's like well you got
to do the upgrade purchase and that was
like three hundred and seventy thousand
oh hello hello and that's just the base
level right there and then you purchase
all these different options
alright but ya know it was really funny
was like you know sideshow going on when
we exited Benny's yeah we like a dozen
people all hydrants hit night Rob's
doing the list show up
you can now pop open the trunk in the
hood and your doors to basically show
off what you're packing so yeah you can
add like air filters and like new engine
and chrome-plated oh I saw all that bass
no its trunk yeah you could get like LED
lit speakers it's awesome so after we
got bored with our van up with a million
speakers we decided to take Lamar up on
a mission that he had for us and he told
us to go get friends like a heist yeah
so it was actually kind of like a co-op
double team two teams in each a lowrider
right go stir the pot up with the
gangsters get them to fight each other
it was basically just a running like
drive and shoot out the window mission
but yeah and you got a had to keep the
lowriders intact and it was pretty fun
that was one of I believe a few more
Lamar contact missions what they're
called and then you get those it's
called luxury engraving so we get two
new weapons you get a machete that I
used and it was terrifying just I ramped
this woman and just like rude machete on
her skull great there's that there's a
new pistol machine pistol but it's
actually technically a submachine gun
it's like that kind of class that's
really cool there's just so much well I
mean you doing a video every single
update right how does this one compare
this one's great I think this one is
better than most
Latta last they've been with the whole
hydraulics and the custom shop like
that's huge
it's like a new location you know they
got Lamar they brought him it's faux
it's always cool when they bring in like
the voice actor again
Ramar is just the best all of the
character so yeah he's at his prime here
so I think it's a little bit better yeah
I think after the heist soo they really
have a grasp on how to do these missions
correctly it's technically free but you
have to buy all the cool stuff
so you might do a little grind but I
think it's great let's wrap it up here
thanks for talking about this update Rob
remind me what it's called again this is
lowriders DLC lowrider GTA online
[Music]